when you call something cageless the
question is were you caged
I think what's awesome about it and in
its in its sort of package form is this
like juxtaposition of this harder
sounding title and this sort of this is
like imagery that's kind of light back
and beautiful and I think where we fit
into that is in this sense of liberation
in a way and freedom in a sense of kind
of I think Headley has arrived at this
place where we've sort of discovered a
new lease on life we've arrived at this
place where we truly have found our
groove in a sense and feel comfortable
in ourselves and I think that speaks to
a lot of our flights as individuals
where it's it's 2017 and I think people
still struggle with feeling confident
with who they are as individuals input
as a personality is sexually you know
and I think it's an era where we all
really want to feel like we belong and
somewhere and I think Headley really has
this cohesion now where we are on this
beautiful path and we've kind of worked
to get to this place and it feels great
and how much of that has to do with age
because the stuff you're doing now and
the attitude you have in the confidence
you have and that's sort of comfortable
in your own skin that you are probably
would not have happened in your early
twenties yeah
it takes time to get to that point like
you know we first started playing
together we were essentially which we
didn't know each other in high school
no so we didn't have that but we kind of
found each other later in life and at
this point now 12 years down I think
we're having more fun if not as much fun
as when we started but we're happy being
happy right we are comfortable in the
skin that we're in and that's a really
cool feeling
what are you working through your own
stuff my brother life's a complete mess
okay constantly it's not like getting my
life's in shambles but I really find
that go through that roller coaster a
lot and it has to do with the way I am
but I love really hard and strong and
then fall apart and have to rebuild and
go through these cycles and it's
probably a little masochist deep down
but at the same time it's I think it's
just a lot of passion all the time
wherever it's like fully and fully out
fully no idea what's going on and it
lends itself to always show it up to
practice be like right there you could
do that which one mode and I'm not
entirely sure which of these two worlds
motivates the other
fans of the band may notice something
different with the release of this album
the band has picked up a new drummer
j.bennison this is the first time I've
met UJ how are you fitting at are you
loving this world I'm the luckiest guy
these guys for ten years I've been
family and to have their approval and
welcomed me as I mean options the most
natural phase of Vancouver boy I watched
Tommy recorded bass on the first record
I mean I saw their first show in
Vancouver or some times so we have a
great history together already you know
it's a natural fit most importantly our
vision is really aligned and don't for a
second think that the band has forgotten
the reason they are where they are today
the fans we're all music fans yeah we
grew up as music fans that we became for
music fans room playing instruments
together and and then we started having
music fans yeah and I think that's what
has rejuvenated us over and over again
throughout the years that's what
motivates us and drives us as we've
grown up so of our fans and we've
evolved and grown together and it almost
sounds cheesy but I say it not just
because I have to but because I know
that's the truth and I know the band
knows Institute but it's because of
those fans have supported us and
believed in us through these years that
we're still able to do this and so
that's truly who we make it for
[Applause]